but first
runaway democrats that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
congratulations dems because in
president biden's 19th month in office
he's the equivalent of a lame duck now
here's the definition according to
oxford languages this is an official
especially the president in the final
period of office after the election of a
successor
or an ineffectual or unsuccessful person
or thing
okay the primary definition might not
apply but the secondary one certainly
does talk about ineffectual that's joe
biden and everyone knows it
now you remember that movie runaway
train right well meet the runaway
democrats
do you want joe biden to run in 2024
no i don't i think the country would be
well served by a new generation of
compelling well-prepared dynamic
democrats
to step up
well congressman phillips is not alone
here in minnesota
you can feel the anxiety building among
democrats not just in the twin cities
but in the burbs as well
now another demo
democrat minnesota angie craig also
doesn't want biden running again saying
we need new leaders in washington
and then in an exchange that has tongues
a wagon two new york liberals in a hot
primary also signal the end is near for
biden
should president biden run again in 2024
mr nadler
too early to say it doesn't serve the
purpose of the democratic party to
to deal with that until after the
midterms miss maloney i don't believe
he's running for re-election
of course the true believers then
pretended to be in shock
he's got to say wow i i'm
really thrown off
that's news to joe biden i think
yeah the guy um
the guy sitting there watching uh these
two i would be very very disappointed
actually i really would i'm yeah that's
really
that's stunning actually
okay that's just bad acting they're not
disappointed
now maloney got clobbered all day long
by party leadership so she tried to walk
it back today tweeting i will absolutely
support president biden if he decides to
run for reelection biden's leadership
securing historic investments for health
care climate and economic justice prove
once again why he is the strong and
effective leader we need right now come
on
but we all know the damage is already
done right
and then the climate change sell out
from coal country he added fuel to the
biden funeral pyre as well would you
support joe biden if he's on the ticket
in 2024 i'm not talking about the 2022
election and 2024. i have no control
over those elections you're a democratic
senator just i'm just asking you you
would support your own the leader of
your own party talking about i'm
supporting this bill andrea
okay
what he's not supporting there is a guy
who has spent more time covered positive
than positive about the names of members
of his own cabinet
i want to thank the
the
former general i keep calling him
general my
my
the guy who runs that outfit over there
and the reason i asked mitch mc to do
this
is because he knows how to get things
done now uh you i'm going to hand it
over to secretary
mr secretary i'm going to have you speak
now
of course the democrats have no one to
blame here but themselves this is a mess
they've created
by running a hologram septogenarian with
rapidly declining cognitive skills then
pairing him up with willie brown's
dimwitted former flame
they box themselves in
now the only thing scarier than biden
with a finger near the nuclear button is
kamala 100 yards from it
it can move clean energy from where it
is created
to where it is needed it is literally
about the transportation of energy
how exciting is that
so the devastation is real
the harm is real
the impact is real
and we are witnessing it in real time
democrats are anti-american radicals but
they're not total morons they're seeing
the same polls that we're seeing the
same kamal the same joe we're seeing
check out this poll from cnn it found
that a shocking 75 percent of democrat
voters want someone other than biden in
2024 and the latest gallup survey
has biden's approval lower than any
president at this point in his first
term ever
it's a personal low of 38 percent
now and despite the endless tedious
january 6 hearings and the relentless
media hits trump is still beating biden
and harris in a hypothetical 2024
matchup
now remember we told you this a few
weeks ago
liberals are never going to admit never
that liberalism has failed
joe biden has consistently pursued these
left-wing policies and we know those
policies have led to one disaster
disaster after another
yet we're waiting for that honest you
know that self-assessment but it never
comes
they can never admit that the lockdowns
lasted too long or that the government
has been too soft on crime or that
democrats blew it on inflation
because that would be admitting a
problem with liberalism and they're
never going to do that
so the problem they think it has to be
biden he's too old he's too weak he
doesn't fight hard enough blah blah blah
so now they're thinking
maybe maybe we could replace him with
someone new maybe
gavin newsom or mayor pete or
maybe just maybe we can convince
michelle to run
like any of them
is going to fix the damage that these
people have done
of course they can't what needs to
change are the policies not the
messaging or even the messenger
until there's a fundamental turn away
from socialism
america's predicament will only worsen
and then one by one all those runaway
democrats who turned against biden
will just be run over themselves and
that's the angle hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else